it's a girl for Emily Blunt and John  Krasinski John tweeted that big  announcement on Monday writing what  better way to celebrate the fourth and  announced our fourth family member  two weeks ago we met our beautiful  daughter Violet hashtag happy fourth  Emily and John tied the knot in 2010 and  they're already parents a two year old  daughter hazel  when ET caught up with Emily back in  April the actress revealed how she was  going to prepare hazel her new siblings  she's a bit dismissive of the idea at  the moment she's quite liking being top  dog I think my plan is just to tell her  that this is less about having a sibling  and more that she's been promoted and  she gets to have a worker now you know  who she could boss around you know  that's so that's kind of a good tactic I  think